hi it's Matthew martinet details and we  just came from the Rick Nolan show this  season Rick Owens is very structured not  as creepy as it usually is which I  thought was very interesting the Panther  Rick Owens were all about a high-waisted  trouser which was great it had about the  middle of the case which was incredible  but it actually looked really cool there  were these great puffer jackets in the  show they were extremely voluminous and  they gave you a really strong broad  shoulder the sleeves on the jackets over  trimmer which was a nice touch one of my  favorite pieces was this amazing cropped  double-breasted jacket the only had one  button so it was super modern and really  really slick but also very futuristic  since a lot of the pieces are statement  pieces it might be easier to pull off if  you broke them up and combined them with  things you already have in your own  closet follow me on Twitter at details  madam for more videos from Paris check  out details calm